foreign
[Music]
what you might call the stereotypical
American suburbs uh if you could picture
that and I cannot walk to the sidewalk
uh in front of my house about 20 meters
from my front door thousands and
thousands and thousands of people here
in just in Western New York State have
lost power for a period of hours and uh
they're just coping with extra blankets
and lots of Christmas sweaters
foreign
[Music]
this may turn out to be the worst storm
in our community's history there are
still likely hundreds of people still
stuck in vehicles
including individuals who tried to drive
out in the late night hours last night
foreign
[Music]
we don't know what's going to happen
whether or not they have extra flights
for tonight or they're saying maybe they
won't even have flights tomorrow
so it's Christmas it sucks
[Music]
foreign